hallo zusammen wir machen heute
erdbeertrilette mein normales Toilette
also das mit der Karamellsoße das kann
ja mega gut bei euch an das ist auch
meines meiner liebsten Rezepte um
ehrlich zu sein und ich weiß nicht ob es
das jetzt noch mal toppen wird weil das
könnt ihr das ganze Jahr über machen da
müsste jetzt nicht auf die Erdbeersaison
warten und es wird auch eine Erdbeer
Vanille trilette weil Vanille wird ja
auch ein großes Thema sein und ich
starte jetzt direkt mit der Zubereitung
und schreibe euch wie immer alle ganz
genauen Mengenangaben hier unten in die
Infobox und ich habe jetzt hier die
Küchenmaschine ihr dürft natürlich auch
euer Handrührgerät verwenden hier geht's
einfach nur schneller und es schlägt ein
bisschen besser auf und ich habe jetzt
hier Eier die werde ich jetzt trennen
und da ist ganz wichtig das ist sauber
drin denn wenn ein bisschen Eigelb im
Eiweiß ist dann lässt sich die Masse
nicht mehr schön aufschlagen
[Musik]
so das Eiweiß wird zusammen mit dem Salz
ca 30 Sekunden angeschlagen ihr merkt
dann dass ich das Volumen verdoppelt
oder auch verdreifacht und danach gebt
ihr Zucker und können auch schon
Vanilleextrakt dazu geben und schlag das
noch mal richtig schön fest ca
eineinhalb Minuten lang richtig festen
[Musik]
so die Baisermasse ist fertig die ist
richtig schön steif genau so muss sie
sein und jetzt mache ich was was sehr
untypisch eigentlich ist und zwar gebe
ich jetzt das Eigelb zur Baisermasse
weil eigentlich heißt es ja kein Fett zu
wir sehen was aber jetzt im Nachgang ist
das möglich und sogar wichtig und
wichtig ist aber auch dass ihr das nur
so kurz wie notwendig unterrührt und
anschließend kommen die trockenen
Zutaten rein das sind nur noch
Backpulver und mehr kurz vorab
miteinander verrühren reinziehen so kurz
wie notwendig einrühren und dann ist die
Masse fertig
[Musik]
so die Masse ist jetzt fertig wie gesagt
so kurz wie notwendig unterrühren weil
wenn du zu lange rührt dann schlagt ihr
wieder die ganze Luft raus und genau das
wollen wir nicht weil das ist ja
wirklich ein super fluffiger ein Wolken
weicher Kuchen ich habe jetzt hier meine
eckige Backform und ich nehme jetzt
heute keine Auflaufform ich wollte euch
einfach zeigen dass es auch mit einer
Springform klappen wird womit ist jetzt
nicht so gut klappen wird ist mit einem
Backrahmen das empfehle ich euch nicht
weil da habt ihr einfach keinen Boden
klar könnt ihr das einschlagen und so
weiter aber später kommt der noch die
Milch trinke drauf und das wird euch
dann alles von den Seiten wegfließen
auch hier wird was
rauskommen später aber ihr habt ja
diesen extrem tiefen und großen
Auslaufschutz daher passt das und ich
weiß es ist total random ich habe
wirklich kein so viel mehr daher muss
ich jetzt das Backpapier aus dem Café
nehmen und eigentlich mache ich sogar so
dass ich bei meinen Springform wegen der
Beschichtung gar kein Backpapier mehr
brauche aber in diesem Teig ist er jetzt
gar kein Öl gar kein Butter mit drin
deswegen mache ich jetzt einfach
sicherheitshalber so aber bei Teigen die
wirklich öl und Butter enthalten braucht
ihr das eigentlich gar nicht so einmal
das Backpapier rein dann den Teig
einfüllen den Ofen habe ich auch schon
vorgeheizt das ist ganz wichtig dass den
vorheizt auf 180 Grad Ober und
Unterhitze aber ich schreibe euch ja
alle ganz genau die Details noch mal in
die Infobox so und jetzt einmal
einfüllen glatt verstreichen und dann
backen
[Musik]
nach 24 Minuten ist der Kuchen komplett
gar ich nehme jetzt hier meine
Winkelpalette die ist nämlich schön
flach dann kann ich hier einmal am Rand
entlang damit ich mir da auch nicht
wegreise ziehen wir sonst immer gerne
mein backformlöser aber bei
beschichteten Produkten solltet ihr das
nicht benutzen sondern einfach lösen
einmal stürzen der ist jetzt auch noch
lauwarm ich habe ihn jetzt nur so lange
abkühlen lassen sich die Form anfassen
kann und lauwarm stürzen und dann
umgedreht wieder reinlegen das machen
aus dem Grund damit die offenen Poren
oben sind und wir das ganze jetzt
trinken aber einfach um das ganze noch
mal zu bestärken und damit die Tränke
gleich noch besser reinkommt nehme ich
mir gleich ein und werde einfach so ein
paar Mal reinstechen
[Musik]
so hier haben wir jetzt alle
Vorkehrungen getroffen und jetzt
verrühren wir unsere drei Milchsorten
miteinander es ist nicht traditionell
ich glaube traditionell wird auch
Büffelmilch verwendet aber ich mag es
lieber auf diese Weise ich habe hier
Milch ich habe Sahne und gezuckerte
Kondensmilch und das ist auch der Grund
warum ich den Teig so wenig Zucker habe
weil die ganze süße kommt jetzt
eigentlich aus der gezuckerten
kondensmäßig verrühre das ganz kurz
miteinander und dann geben wir das auf
den noch lauwarm Kuchen und dann kann
das ganze schön einziehen und ich zeige
euch im Anschluss wie wir die leckere
quarksahnecreme machen
[Musik]
so hier kann ich euch auch ganz genau
zeigen hier läuft auf jeden Fall ein
bisschen Milch aus und das ist ganz
normal das coole an dieser auffangrille
ist ich schieb das jetzt einfach wieder
zurück in mein Behälter und gebe das
dann wieder oben drüber das würde zum
Beispiel bei einem Backrahmen natürlich
nicht funktionieren könnt auch direkt
eine Auflaufform verwenden das ist auch
kein Problem also ein bisschen Verlust
ist immer normal das ist auch gar nicht
schlimm und ich gebe das jetzt an die
Seite zum Kühlen und zeige euch jetzt
eben die quarksahne Creme die geht
nämlich auch sehr schnell und einfach
die können auf jeden Fall vorbereiten
wichtig ist dass die Sahne jetzt ganz
kalt und frisch aus dem Kühlschrank
kommt und nicht mit Zimmertemperatur hat
dadurch dass es so eine geringe Menge
ist nämlich jetzt einfach mein
Handrührgerät und rühre das einmal steif
zusammen mit Sahnefest und was ja auch
nicht fehlen darf ist ein bisschen
Vanilleextrakt für den Geschmack
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt ganz kurz den Quark mit
Puderzucker verrührt vorher sieben damit
da keine dicken Klümpchen drin sind
wichtig ist dass ihr da wirklich nur so
5 Sekunden lang rührt und die
Flüssigkeit sich jetzt eben nicht trennt
und der Quark schön fest bleibt ich gebe
den Quark jetzt hier zu Sahne und würde
mit meinem Teigschaber kurz unter und
dann kann diese Creme gleich auf den
abgekühlten Boden wir können einfach mit
der Hand immer fühlen aber abgekühlt ist
dann gibt er das oben drüber und können
das auch schön glatt verstreichen ich
hatte bei meinem ersten trilette Rezept
übrigens diese Sahne Schicht dazwischen
und wenn man beim zweiten Toilette
Rezept ich habe ja zwei schon auf meinem
Kanal aber die klassische Variante mit
Karamell und da gab es wirklich
gespaltene Meinungen einige Fans mit der
Quark Sahne Schicht besser andere sagen
direkt Soße bzw Karamell oder im
Erdbeersoße auf den schönen milchkuchen
und in dem Fall dachte ich einfach ich
mache wieder so eine leckere Schicht und
guck mal die Masse ist richtig schön
fluffig passt also zum Kuchen und sobald
die Oberfläche abgekühlt ist gebe ich
das dann einfach nur noch oben drauf
[Musik]
so ich habe die Toilette jetzt noch mal
für 30 Minuten in den Kühlschrank getan
einfach damit die Oberfläche jetzt nur
noch schön sitzt und schön erkaltet und
fest wird und jetzt kommt natürlich die
trinette Soße zum Einsatz und ihr kennt
ihr alle die Karamellsoße die macht ihr
inzwischen auch in ein Eiskaffee oder
ein andere Desserts und damit habe ich
auch schon ganz viele Varianten hier vom
Kanal gezeigt und ganz neu ist jetzt
hier die Erdbeeren Soße ihr habt sehr
lange drauf gewartet hat übertrieben
lange auch gedauert bis das stand und
jetzt steht ist jetzt ist sie glaube ich
gerade bei uns eingetroffen ich verlinke
euch in die Infobox und das coole ist
auch hier einfach Deckel abnehmen und
dann super handlich damit mache ich auch
mit Sicherheit Getränke und so weiter
werde ich euch alles zeigen jetzt könnte
einfach super handlich das ganze hier
drauf geben gar keine Mühe geben leute
es wird immer gut aussehen und ich
Schwenk dann gleich einfach noch mal ähm
die Form und dann verteilt sich alles
ihr könnt auch mit einem mit einer
Winkelpalette rein da ist einfach so ein
Ding total gelingt sicher und noch
Anfänger geeignet und das coole ist dass
die auch wieder durchsichtig ist wie
auch bei der Karamellsoße
[Musik]
so jetzt kommt natürlich unsere typische
Toilette Optik da könnt ihr entweder
Kuvertüre vermischt mit Kokosfett nehmen
oder in dem einfach mit Joy es ist für
sich eine milchkuchen oder ihr könntet
auch das kann ich euch auch einmal
zeigen ihr könntet auch die strawberry
cream nehmen dann habt ihr so Yogurette
Vibes mit drin stehe ich mir auch sehr
lecker vor optisch wollte ich gerne
Weisheiten daher nehme ich jetzt die
Milch Joy cream die schmeckt ja wie das
Innere von Kinderriegel das ist so krass
so verblüffend so und die habe ich kurz
in der Mikrowelle erwärmt damit sie
schön flüssig wird wird aber auch wieder
fest jedoch nicht knackig wenn es egal
ist also eigentlich die perfekte Glasur
so vorne dran habe ich eine Lochtülle
und auch hier braucht euch keine Sorgen
machen es sieht immer schön aus also ihr
werdet für für krumme und schiefe
Streifen aber gleich komme ich mit dem
Schaschlikspieß und dann kommt da das
wunderschöne Muster rein wie gesagt auch
da falls wir gestern gemacht die werden
so begeistert sein auch wenn es super
easy ist sieht super aus wenn ich aus
[Musik]
so ich hatte dieses wunderschöne
Prachtstück jetzt noch mal für 15
Minuten im Kühlschrank einfach damit die
oberste Schicht jetzt auch noch sitzt
und wir das hier vernünftig anschneiden
können mit einmal den Rahmen ab so und
dann werde ich das in Schnittchen
aufteilen und servieren und dann gibt's
gleich noch den Test
[Musik]
dieses ja klar
ihr braucht keine Zähne dafür perfekt
für
ältere Herrschaften
ü80
haben ich habe es gar nicht mehr gehört
weil ich dieses ich bin schon so auf
Wolke 7 ja das ist der Hammer das ist
der Hammer Leute ich sag's euch mein
neues Liebling
[Musik]
aber hier ist der Geschmack auch mega
geil
e Apple also mega Leute unbedingt nach
wirklich 12 von 10 Punkte
oben drauf genau
auf jeden Fall gebe ich 12 von zehn
Punkte das ist so lecker und so leicht
das ganze Jahr über machen
im nächsten Rezept wenn ihr denn meinen
Kanal kostenlos abonnieren bitte
wirklich
[Musik]